hi I'm Megan from Khan Academy and in
this video we'll browse through Khan
Academy together
we'll start by logging into the platform
and then go through some of the key
navigation features together to get
started go to Khan Academy org and click
teachers in the center of the screen if
you have an existing Khan Academy
account select login if you need to
create a Khan Academy account there are
four registration options using gmail
clever Facebook or another email account
now you're ready to get started once
you've setup your account you'll start
on the teacher dashboard we are now
viewing the teacher dashboard which is
the home page for teachers if you are
seeing a different homepage than the
teacher dashboard you can adjust your
homepage to the teacher dashboard in
settings don't worry we'll get to that
soon there are a few important items on
this page the courses button which shows
Khan Academy's content organized by
subject and course the search bar which
you can use to find content quickly by
name or standard the Khan Academy logo
that will always take you to your chosen
homepage and the navigation button which
allows you to access several other pages
the navigation button which appears as
your username can take you to a few
essential locations including the
learner homepage teacher dashboard
parent dashboard and settings
if you want to edit your basic
information you can do this from the
settings page from the drop down of the
navigation button from the settings page
you can edit basic account information
like user name and primary language
reset your password know which email
account is linked to Khan Academy select
your home page and much more it is
important to check if the teacher
function is selected because only then
will you have access to the teacher
dashboard
we're selecting the teacher dashboard
from the drop down menu if you'd like to
learn more about the learner homepage
check out our video on the student
experience from the teacher dashboard
you will find three very important tabs
the class tab shows all of your active
classes if you select a class you'll be
able to view the roster student activity
mastery progress and assignments for
that class we will discuss reports in
more detail in a later lesson if we
return to the main teacher dashboard by
selecting the Kahn Academy logo at the
top of the page the second tab you will
see is the students tab on which you can
view the complete list of students who
are connected to your teacher account
this list contains all of the students
currently associated with your teacher
account regardless of their assigned
class finally from the main teacher
dashboard you can access the resources
tab which brings you to teacher facing
materials on Khan Academy and also has a
shortcut to Khan for educators we
recognize that along with your students
many teachers want to connect their own
children to their Khan Academy account
from the navigation button you can
access the parent dashboard where
parents can add their children and
create accounts for them in addition to
monitoring the progress they are
achieving with courses on the platform
one last and important thing to point
out where to find additional help if you
need it by clicking help from the
navigation button drop down menu you
have access to a page full of resources
about Khan Academy community advice and
you can even file a request for help
from our support team to resolve any
technical issues that arise we hope this
video helps you find your way around
Khan Academy